pour angers populaire on est quand même
se dire autant des gones pas les gars
[Musique]
cb
nous sommes au mwc à barcelone gros
salon de la téléphonie mobile
si vous suivez la cupule quelques jours
où ça vous aura pas échappé il ya
différents contre on a parlé de sony on
a parlé de huawei on a parlé si on me l
a parlé de plein de choses il ya tout le
monde qui est là il ya aussi bien les
vendeurs pour coller tout ça
bon je vous en passe et des meilleures
il ya tout ou partie de business est en
train de négocier parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que au mwc
on vise à faire du business on vient par
an nour au public c'est un salon
professionnel donc les marques se
retrouvent avec leurs fournisseurs avec
les distributeurs
rien que business ce fait c'est le
commentaire le point central aujourd'hui
je pense de business de la téléphonie
mobile alors si c'est intéressant on y
parle 5g on y parle de plein de choses
on y découvre les nouvelles technologies
on y découvre un nouveau smartphone des
nouveaux usages des trucs très
intéressant donc on voit vraiment
l'intérêt des trucs complètement votre
sofa qui serviront système en rien et
qu' on va finir probablement pas oublier
dit si tout est toujours allez savoir
et il ya aussi des choses intéressantes
alors aujourd'hui je vous emmène voir
rico au micro qui présente des nouveaux
smartphones
une nouvelle gamme view 3 view 3 pro il
va y avoir pas mal de nouveautés chez we
go cette année il ya une
internationalisation
combien titulaire tandis mans où nico
s'ouvre à l'international alors gatineau
qui a repris we con il ya
l'année dernière si je dis pas de
bêtises et cette année et annonce
effectivement l'attaquent du marché
américain
donc ça c'est cool ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on aille faire un tour
directement chez eux si je trouve
l'entrée du hall 6
c'est tellement grand ici construire on
va les voir hui qu on va les voir vont
pas tarder on va aller voir ce qui se
passe chez eux
on va aller voir ses produits revoir ci
sont cool on va tous mourir enfin bref
vous connaissez l'histoire on y va
[Musique]
nous voilà au mwc avec hervé hervé de
huy coloré revue on l'a vu un paquet de
fois dans la vidéo si vous suivez l'actu
ça va très bien au top alors beaucoup de
nouveautés beaucoup d'annonceurs au mwc
coup beaucoup d'annoncés notamment notre
arrivée sur le marché américain
si vous passez dans les prochaines
semaines on va lancer un produit avec
sprint dans le quatrième plus gros
opérateurs américains d'accor donc pour
nous c'est vraiment un
on arrive sur le continent américain
avec deux bureaux un dallas à atlanta et
on est vraiment raide tu m'étonnes tu me
donnes un gros gros gros gros challenge
pour ricoh gros challenge et puis
surtout on potentiellement on multiplie
par deux notre base de potentiel de
ventes donc c'est pour nous une très
grosse ambition et une belle image très
belles images en plus le marché
américain c'est un marché très très en
avance sur la scène j'ai d'accord et en
cinq jours les padres parce qu'on vient
d'avoir un prix red dot award sur
justement un routeur wifi sunji qui
s'appelle le fac j'ai dingue ce génial
bompard fait alors là où en ewc vous
avez présenté de nouveaux produits de
nouveaux produits obsédé du 3 view 3 pro
qui vient de succéder au vieux de vieux
de pro tout à fait de l'année dernière
celui où alors qu'elle y aden deux de
ses productions
alors très clairement ce qu'il faut
retenir sur sept lycées la triple caméra
c'est la première fois que wilko
smartphone triple caméras sur le view 3
il quittera pro vous avez jolie en même
temps on redécouvre ensemble j'ai déjà
vu un petit peu
il ya quelques jours je le revois
aujourd'hui je peux tu est plus tard
quand sa sortie pour l'instant c'est pas
possible de faire le test on n'a pas
accès au téléphone pour aller se balader
faire des photos clips comment imposer
d'alors un vieux troyes on a un triple
capteur arrière 12 13 2 mégapixels alors
on va avoir un 12 mégapixels c'est la
caméra sony celle à 486 qui va être la
caméra principale le 13 mai à 17 qu'une
caméra grand angle ça ça ça se fait
beaucoup aujourd'hui sur ces typologies
smartphones c'est effectivement voilà
vous êtes avec des amis tout le monde
parce que sur la photo on souffle sur le
grand emprunt ou général on perd un peu
en qualité
à voir sans verra sur le test et après
vous avez une caméra de 2 mégapixels sur
le vieux troyes qui va servir pour le
modbook et pour l'été portrait pour la
profondeur et une caméra de 5 mégapixels
sont le view 3 pro sur le modèle pro
vous avez une caméra de 16 mégapixels à
l'avant tandis que sur l'autre vous avez
une caméra de 8 mégapixels la caméra
celle fille vous avez bien évidemment
google assistant qui marche au pied
google prend les photos cl fils comme
boulez s'écoule et notamment sur le
vieux 3 blu ray etc un produit qui a un
dos en verre c'est la première fois
qu'on fait un dos en verre avec de l'usb
c'est donc une charge rapide même permet
effectivement de bénéficier
de son smartphone et de le charger très
rapidement ça c'est un truc avec un peu
vu en commentaire à gens disaient oui
kohail a pas du sbc ça yaya buèges décès
sur votre modèle le plus haut de gamme
alors c'est une très bonne remarque
parce que c'est qu'on s'efforce à chaque
fois d'écouter ce que nous disent le
consommateur notamment vient
effectivement les guides et les
commentaires que tu peux avoir sur la
chaîne rai est aujourd'hui effectivement
on voulait avoir un modèle usb c'est on
voulait avoir des modèles avec une très
grosse autonomie de la batterie d'accord
donc tous nos modèles des 99 euros doit
avoir une batterie de 4 millions +4
millions par an c'est le minimum à temps
chez lui collait à partir de 99 euros en
dessous effectivement il y aura une
capacité un peu un peu moins puisque
c'est justement là des chiffres en
termes d'autonomie alors une fois de
plus un je m'appuie sur ma montrent un
dossier de presse alors ça a été fait à
merveille m'expliquer en fait ce sont
pas des chiffres
oui qu il passe par un institut
indépendant qui l'a vraiment mesuré avec
des tests drastiques auxquelles les
chiffres sont certifiés tran musique en
streaming il donne 60 et 1h30 d'écouté
de musique alors vraiment si vous faites
ça du début jusqu'à la fin de la
batterie c'est un prix politique appelle
en 2g 36 heures jeux vidéo
11h30 lecture de vidéo off line pas
online et offline rayon déjà les vidéos
dans votre décade 18 heures auxquelles
pas mal la navigation sur internet en
wifi 20h et navigation soit tête avec
une carte sim
13 heures fondamentalement une batterie
qui veulent fermer 500 a testé il sort
au mode mais d'ondés que il sera sorti
on va faire le test ensemble et je
pourrais vous en dire davantage
ces smartphones qu'est ce qu'il raconte
l'histoire c'est quoi il s'adresse à qui
c'est c'est quoi leur adn alors pour
nous sont des smartphones plutôt gamme
parce que tu sais on a des produits tron
59 à 299 euros
le vus 3 est positionné à 179 euros
le reste c'est déjà pourri on va dire
milieu de gamme et haut de gamme pour
eux comme m6 et de l'entrée de gamme
pour beaucoup de marques et on va avoir
sur le vieux troyes proa modèle à 249
euros avec une capacité 64 6 4 au niveau
de la rom et d'aram d'accord et on va
avoir 128 +6 amerell à 299 euros
maintenant tous qu'en gros on booste la
performance de nos produits on monte en
gamme sur nos produits sont montés en
gamme sur les prix parce qu'on maintient
des prix en dessous de 300 lieux trois
ans dans l'écran de 6 26 pouces et du hd
+ et sur liu 3 points d'un écran de 6,3
pouces fhd plus ça c'est assez cool le
son que d une belle montée en gamme par
rapport aux bons vieux deux vieux de
croo le temps que le view 3 pro
franchement il n'a pas à rougir et
appâts roja parce que oui quoi vraiment
fait un des efforts ça c'est vraiment
intéressant déjà au niveau de l'appareil
photo sans testera on verra mais la
volonté déjà de se mettre à jour par
rapport aux autres concurrents du marché
sur un triple 14 ça c'est franchement
intéressant parce que dans cette gamme
de prix
il n'y a pas forcément toujours des
triples capteurs en plus ce qui est cool
c'est cet écran
6 1 nul 3 pouces fhd plus vu une bonne
résolution racho 19/9 avoir la qualité
de la dalle
mais ça on en reparlera aussi en des
phases de test le fennec 2 de l'usb type
c'est ça c'est aussi très intéressant
c'est très malin parce que c'était
vraiment une critique qui a été fait en
dehors du court les ans à holy cow c'est
toujours du micro usb ya plein de gens
qui nous protège mais bon là où ricco
enfin pas en avant ça leur coûte un peu
plus cher j'imagine à produire que un
smartphone en micro usb
néanmoins il ya de la recharge rapide
oms à répondre vraiment aux besoins de
consommateurs pourquoi une batterie 4
millions période arrière c'est un vrai
sens en termes de nouveaux du soc sur le
levier ou trois pros c'est un
médiathèque s'améliorer 60 tout à fait
et sur le jus croit le seul but 3 on
améliorer 22 on est des premières
marques à mettre sur le marché un
smartphone écrits du père en deuil qui
le tout dernier processeur de médiateur
et après il y en a qui râleront disant
ouais il pouvait être un médiathèque
anja diop et 60
ok sauf que en fait oui cause une
équation à plus compliqué ils sortent
des smartphones pas cher même si moins
de 300 euros à bien c'est un petit but
je suis d'accord mais par rapport à ce
qui se fait de la concurrence c'est pas
cher alors ils ont pas la capacité
d'achat en masse par exemple comme
projeté des slams dragon's de qualcomm
ils ont ils vont pas les acheter au même
prix du coup il se rabat entre
guillemets chez mediatek où ils vont
acheter forcément moins cher ce qui leur
permettra d'être beaucoup plus
compétitif pour le consommateur final
parce que s'il devait trouver
l'équivalent en termes de puissance et
chez qualcomm ça leur coûterait
fondamentalement plus cher que le même
produit chez mediatek on va dire ah
mince c'est pas un stade rigole ok c'est
un délit au p 60
c'est vrai mais deux côtés lorsque vous
allez acheter un smartphone à moins de
300 euros
on va pas le temps d'avoir des
performances de ouf on va pas se rendre
à voir une machine de dingue
néanmoins derrière également un bel
effort qui est fait au niveau de la
rappeuse est quand même si giga de ram
donc un smartphone qui sera suffisamment
fluide
on dit je dirais trois quarts du
catalogue du googleplex assez
intéressant et à mon avis c'est défend
un faux débat de se dire dans cette
gamme de prix sur ce produit là est liée
aux pelles 60 sur un dragon
voilà ça je tempère un peu parce que je
pense que et on verra lors des phases de
test à mon avis on n'a pas sentir un
smartphone qui rappelons-le concerne la
prise jack tout à fait ok double sim
double sim alors sur les modèles view 3
pro on a dû à 2,6 mhz qui sert également
de ce lot pour l'extension mémoire
d'accord que très bien alors grosse
batterie smartphone suffisamment fluide
dans ce type d' usage on s'adresse à qui
on s'adresse alors qu'on nous plutôt à
des cadets
la cible consommateurs de ricoh ça reste
le 18 24 mai sur ce niveau de prix 179
249 ou 299 euros c'est plutôt un jeune
adulte mais qui travaillent déjà c'est
plus on n'est pas sur un récif le
teenager on est plutôt effectivement sur
le personne la cave est l'opportunité de
pouvoir quand même investir 300 euros
dans les smartphones et une somme quand
même ok très bien alors comme enrico
photo bien oui connaît très bien mais
nous allons être très bien on est
aujourd'hui numéro 4
le marché
européen en europe de l'ouest toujours
numéro trois en france au caire et donc
on est hyper content parce que dans un
heureux je m'entraîne très très
compétitif avec un marché qui baisse est
de près de 5% en volume mais qu'il
augmente de 5% en valeur
on a eu malgré tout à maintenir des
positions et de parts de marché donc on
est vraiment très bien joué c'est vrai
qu'il ya une grosse montée de la
concurrence de l'année dernière et il
m'a dit vous arrivez et pas des moindres
avec des acteurs majeurs sur le segment
prix sont au second tour nous clairement
le smartphone locaux trémois du marché
en france aujourd'hui ses 419 euros
la corde un smartphone meego sur tous
les moyens 2018 stressant euros 100
euros
donc on est aujourd'hui numéro un sur ce
segment moins de sens on est numéro
trois sur le segment sciences 150 euros
et en et libéraux 5 sur le segment
150-200 où il ya eu beaucoup d'acteurs
notamment xiaomi aides et d'autres qui
sont arrivés pour new challenge est un
peu sur ce marché bien sûr bien sûr
ok cool alors tu me dis les objectifs et
les emballages ou trois buts 3 project
eu les us mais il y aura d'autres
produits cette année aussi pour
l'occasion de se revoir et d'en reparler
on va se voir mais clairement notre
volonté cette année trop souvent on a
présenté beaucoup beaucoup de produits à
barcelone et du coup on était un peu
paumé même nous les spécialistes
sur ces produits donc on a voulu
vraiment avoir un message unique à
barcelone représente view 3 du 3 promet
bien évidemment courant mais on va
annoncer tout les produits de la gamme y
va car notre gamme un peu entrée de
gamme avec des produits très très
accessible génial merci à vous merci
heureusement on ferme un peu les yeux
parce qu'on a semblé juste là donc ça ça
pique on sait bien on y vient barcelone
là il faudrait dans l'incroyable n'est
pas que l'on est frais ou plus on est au
top
on est au top oh oui qu'on raconte une
belle histoire nico c'est une une boîte
petite boîte française et aujourd'hui
vous avez de tino derrière qui est une
énorme géant de géant chinois
est il vrai des l'évolution une vraie
belle histoire cette idée de dire allez
on se bat on s'internationalise on se
base sur un marché qui est vachement rue
qui est vachement dur pour que ces
courageux
les produits sont sympas il ya de beaux
efforts de fait et j'ai trouvé
intéressant alors on verra ça ensemble
on reste ensemble on en reparlera au
mois de mai parce qu'il va y avoir les
tests de ses smartphones et puis y aura
probablement un événement dans lequel on
allait pouvoir revoir tous nos amis de
la team bigot
c'est plutôt cool dites moi ce que vous
en pensez est ce que vous les trouvez
cool c'est bien trois que trois pros est
ce que vous pensez que le café du bon
job est le dos en verre ça vous paraît
cool sur le doubs trois pros le dégrader
son côté le designer règle générale la
petite encoche budo est ce que vous
pensez que c'est une belle évolution de
la part de la marque
dites moi tout ça embarras et puis bien
évidemment comme d'hab on en discute
ensemble épique il faut bien que les
messages qui seront laissés en bas sont
lus également par rico donc si vous avez
des questions
des revendications des choses construite
un constructif à dayton web ou hasek
[Musique]
quand ça se passe là on est pas mal ça
va petite bière tranquillement sa portée
at-elle on s'en sert sa part tiger
lillies enterrer les gars n oubliez pas
l'abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé
après mais on est charlie mais monsieur
vous me prenez moi
[Musique]
bon les gars je pars avant que la soirée
par vraiment pouilles un pass online et
17h30 un cha cha cha galerie
traçage courant gêne oculaire
on est quand même se dire autant des
campagnards
c'est la fin du ewc pour moi il reste
une journée une journée mais demain je
vous emmène sur entre complètement
incroyable on va aller sur le circuit de
formule 1 de barcelone puisque je suis
parti en voyage de presse avec welcome
et que qualcomm est partenaire de
mercedes formule 1 et qu'en plus ils ont
un pilote qui s'appelle lewis hamilton
je vous laisse imaginer tout ce qui va
ce mois-ci donc ça se passera dès demain
direction le circuit de f1 et je vais
aller visiter les paddocks voir plainte
ou que ça va être
hallucinant donc je donne rendez vous
dès demain et il va ailleurs plein
d'autres contenus sont la mwc que j'ai
filmé je prends garde d'ici quelques
jours vous allez voir on va paraître
plein de choses notamment 200 greffiers
comprendre qu'est-ce que la satire va
nous apporter voilà pour cette année au
revoir en volant le fira au revoir le
mdp lui aussi un héros jadot nous en
masse